ten late last night stormy Daniels
posted her reaction to the verdict on
her Instagram page she writes sadly it
appears what Michael avenatti did to me
was just the tip of the iceberg of
deceit I am not surprised his dishonesty
has been revealed on a grand scale the
first criminal case against disgraced
Hollywood producer Harvey Weinstein is
coming to a close the prosecution here
in New York is seeking a conviction on
five charges of rape and sexual assault
they claim the movie mogul treated his
victims as quote complete disposables as
Weinstein awaits the verdict in his
trial his defense team is preparing to
battle more charges in California
Michael George is here with more Michael
good morning
good morning the prosecution's closing
arguments on Friday cap a dramatic
six-week trial its assistant district
attorney Jonah Lucy spent three hours
were counting the testimony of six women
who allege abuse against Harvey
Weinstein with his fate in the hands of
the jury
disgraced movie mogul Harvey Weinstein
flashed a smile as he limped out of the
New York City courthouse prosecutors
spent hours urging jurors to find
Weinstein guilty of rape and sexual
assaults attorney Gloria Allred
represents one of Weinstein's accusers
mr. Weinstein was powerful he
manipulated these women the 67 year old
is charged with raping a woman in a
hotel room in March of 2013 and forcibly
performing a sex act on another woman in
2006 during closing arguments prosecutor
Jonah Lucy called Weinstein a predator
and master of his universe who viewed
his victims as ants he could step on and
disposable the Hollywood producer
fidgeted and appeared agitated as
illuzzi continued she recounted the
testimony of star witness Annabella she
hora who testified Weinstein raped her
in the early 90s at this point it will
be in the jury's hands we feel good
about where we are
Weinstein's lawyer Donna retino argued
prosecutors created an alternate
universe during closing arguments on
Thursday she also said the prosecution
failed to prove their case beyond a
reasonable doubt this is a case that
should be about evidence it shouldn't be
about emotion
it's
be about feelings that it's not a
popularity contest illuzzi fired back at
those claims stating there are no
blurred lines here this is a crime and a
wanton disregard for other people now
the decision is up to the jury of seven
men and five women and jury
deliberations are expected to begin
Tuesday following the Presidents Day
holiday during the weeks long trial
Weinstein chose not to testify in his
own defense but he maintained any sexual
encounters were consensual he faces
possible life in prison if convicted
Jeff Michael thank you very much
you